encaminados a la legalización tras una
semana de la aprobación del proyecto de
ley que permite la producción
exportación y el uso de cannabis con
fines terapéuticos en marruecos los
cultivadores consideran por primera vez
salir de la ilegalidad
la temporada de cosecha se lleva a cabo
en junio y julio y el proceso de
transformación es hachís empieza en
septiembre el traficante de drogas viene
a comprar la producción del agricultor
ofreciendo el precio que él quiere el
agricultor es pobre y la planta es lo
único que crece aquí porque hace
demasiado frío la tierra no es apta para
cereales no es lo suficientemente fértil
tenemos pequeñas parcelas de tierra a
través del proyecto de ley el gobierno
pretende organizar a los cultivadores en
cooperativas y sancionar a quienes
distribuyan la planta por fuera del
circuito oficial
tenemos miedo como agricultores y
pedimos que se establezcan industrias
que transformen el cannabis para su
consumo médico e industrial y que se
establezcan fábricas para emplear mano
de obra local
pese a las divisiones políticas que ha
generado el proyecto de ley el
parlamento deberá ratificar la decisión
del ejecutivo antes de la
legislativas de septiembre con 47 mil
hectáreas de marihuana sembrada en las
montañas del rif marruecos es uno de los
principales productores de marihuana en
el mundo según la agencia antidrogas de
la onu